only on CBS this morning we spoke to
senator Sanders the latest candidate to
join the 2020 Democratic presidential
race
Sanders responded to some of the
president's criticisms and talked about
lessons he learned from his 2016
campaign what's your opinion of
capitalism look I think what we see in
this country and around the world is a
lot of great entrepreneurs but I think
what is happening is some of these folks
we are have a system which allows these
people to accumulate huge amounts of
income and wealth so when I talk about
democratic socialism somebody wants to
call me a rat achill okay here it is I
believe that people are inherently
entitled to health care I believe people
are entitled to get the best education
they can I believe that people are
entitled to live in a clean environment
people are entitled to have decent
paying jobs that's what I believe the
president mentioned socialism in his
State of the Union what's he going after
there he's gonna appeal he's gonna lie
he's gonna say Bernie Sanders wants the
United States to become Venezuela Bernie
Sanders does not want to have the United
States become the horrific economic
situation that unfortunately exists in
Venezuelan right now but Bernie Sanders
wants is to learn from countries around
the world why other countries doing a
better job in dealing with income and
wealth inequality than we are so you got
a president who is a demagogue a
president who is leading us in an
authoritarian direction I would hope
that the American people don't believe
too much of what he says Democrats you
know this well come to you and say
you're not a Democrat why are you
running in the Democratic primary well
first of all I am a member of the
Democratic leadership I've been in the
Democratic caucus but this is what I
will also say if you look at polling in
this country what you find is that a
whole lot of people are dissatisfied
with both the Democratic and Republican
parties and more and more people are
seeing themselves as independents so if
I if the Democratic Party is going to do
well in the future I think they have to
reach out to those independents
including by the way a lot of young
people a lot of people of color and
bring them into the Democratic Party and
I think I'm gonna good
to do that there were charges in your
last campaign that women felt there was
discrimination against them that there
were sexism you met with some of those
former staffers what did you learn I
learned that was true and it breaks my
heart and you know our campaign kind of
exploded we went from a few people to a
lot of people and I will be very honest
in telling you that in retrospect some
of the people that were hired should not
have been hired and some women went
through experiences that they should not
have but let me also say this in my 2018
campaign for re-election to the United
States Senator from Vermont and in this
campaign for president we are going to
have the strongest protocols to protect
women anybody else against any form of
harassment we are going to be training
every employee who works for us and
we're going to give people who feel that
they've been harassed the opportunity to
talk to people outside of the campaign
so this has been an issue that has upset
me and we're gonna rectify it in this
campaign you'll be 79 when you're
inaugurated yes that's all by the
standards of presidents yes should
people be concerned about that I think
you know when we look at people whether
they're older they're young you got to
look at the totality of the person I'm
sure you have bumped into people 190 who
do great work you have bumped into
people who are 45 or 50 you got to wake
up because they're falling asleep all of
the time I have been blessed thank God
I'm gonna knock this is what I'm gonna
knock on it with with good health and
with good energy ever saw cross-country
runner long-distance running when I was
a kid and I've been running hard in a
sense since then well those are good
questions general well and we had a lot
more which will be online about Amazon
you know he supports the those people
who are protesting against Amazon coming
into Long Island City we talk again
about Medicare for all there's a lot of
questions and follow-up about that and
so it's a lot more that'll be on online
of that interview cBS This Morning Calm
you can see all of that
that's exactly right she is up for the
challenge don't you don't age as many
people say age is just a number that's
right just a number and he certainly is
out there
campaigning quite a lot he also he also
talked about the the 25th amendment and
Andrew McCabe so good stuff